This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is part two, the 2018-2019 mini-stories episodes, where I interview the staff about their favorite little design stories and stories about the built world that don't quite fill out an entire episode for whatever reason, but they are quintessential 99PI stories nonetheless. We have stolen artifacts, mythical alleys, detached US territories, machines that bring joy to people's lives in a 50-foot screaming monster that we will burn to the ground. If you are ever in need of a conversation starter, the many stories are our gift to you. Stay with us. At first, producer Joe Rosenberg. Okay, so Roman, imagine you're watching a TV show,
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。这是2018-2019迷你故事集的第二部分，在这里我将采访工作人员，听他们讲述自己最喜欢的设计小故事，以及关于人造环境的故事。这些故事可能因为各种原因撑不起一整集，但它们依然是典型的 99PI 故事。我们有被盗的文物、神秘的小巷、美国海外领地、为人们的生活带来欢乐的机器，以及一个我们要将其烧成灰烬的50英尺高的尖叫怪物。如果你需要一个打破僵局的话题，这些丰富的故事就是我们送给你的礼物。请继续收听。首先是制片人乔·罗森伯格。好的，罗曼，想象一下你正在看一部电视剧，
like set in New York, and let's say it's one of those buddy cop comedies where they pair the rookie with the grizzled veteran. And it opens, let's say, on a foot chase, you know, they're closing in on their suspects, streets of Manhattan are whizzing by. Let me ask you, like, nine times out of ten. If the suspect ducks around a corner to get away
比如背景设在纽约，假设这是一部搭档警匪喜剧，他们把菜鸟警察和饱经沧桑的老兵配成一组。故事开场，比方说是一场徒步追捕，你知道的，他们正在逼近嫌疑人，曼哈顿的街道在飞速掠过。我问你，十有八九。如果嫌疑人拐过街角企图逃跑
from them, he usually ducks into a what? And Ali, is that what you're looking for? Yes, okay, yeah, I'm kind of leading you on. You are correct. You're not okay. Now imagine another episode, same television show, The Rookie Cop is woken in the middle of the night because there's a fresh body.
甩掉他们，他通常会拐进什么地方？是一条小巷吗，这正是你要找的？是的，没错，好吧，我其实是在引导你。你答对了。你没猜错。现在想象另一集，同样的电视剧，菜鸟警察在半夜被叫醒，因为发现了一具新鲜尸体。
There's been a murder, they need him at the crime scene. Now picture the crime scene, the police day, the chalk outline, where is this crime scene? That is definitely in an alley. Correct, yes, again. And now imagine a humor view for what just to complete the rule of three. In another episode, the grizzly cop breaks up a drug deal. It's going to be in an alley. And that's just for like, you know, a television crime procedural. I mean, imagine like, say all the roles an alley might play in a movie,
发生了一起谋杀案，他们需要他去犯罪现场。现在想象一下这个犯罪现场，警察日，粉笔画出的轮廓，这个犯罪现场在哪里？那绝对是在一条小巷里。没错，答对了，又是这样。现在为了凑齐“事不过三”的法则，再想象一个场景。在另一集中，老练的警察破获了一起毒品交易。地点肯定也是在小巷里。这还只是针对电视上的警匪犯罪剧而言。我是说，想象一下，比如说小巷在电影中可能扮演的所有角色，
you know, set in a New York restaurant. Sure. like if you're, you know, a restaurant worker or a dishwasher, you're taking out the trash and in the back alley, you're like having a secret rendezvous in the back alley, totally. Like that's an alley is where things happen. Right, exactly. It's all alley everything. But the point is that regardless of what's happening
你知道的，背景设在纽约餐馆的那种。当然。比如如果你是个餐馆员工或者洗碗工，你正在倒垃圾，然后在后面的小巷里，你在后巷进行了一场秘密幽会，完全是这样。小巷就是发生事情的地方。对，没错。全都是小巷。但重点是，无论电影或电视剧中正在发生什么，
in the film or the television show, all of these alley scenes help sell audiences on the same idea of New York. That New York is a city of 10,000 alleys, each with its own secret history. There's just one tiny problem with this, which is that there are no alleys in New York. That can't be true. It's hard to wrap your mind around because we've all been raised on thisys in New York. That can't be true. It's hard to wrap your mind around because we've all been raised on this myth that New York has alleys.
所有这些小巷场景都在向观众灌输关于纽约的同一种观念。那就是纽约是一个拥有一万条小巷的城市，每条小巷都有其自己的秘密历史。这里只有一个小问题，那就是纽约根本没有小巷。这不可能是真的。这很难让人接受，因为我们从小就被灌输了这种纽约有小巷的神话。这不可能是真的。这很难让人接受，因为我们从小就被灌输了这种纽约有小巷的神话。
And there are some in the outer burrows, but like if you've spent time in Manhattan and you really search your memory, you will not remember passing by an alleys. At least not like a classic alley that like leads between two streets as the fires could, like usually maybe at best like if there's like a glorified like loading
外围区确实有一些，但如果你在曼哈顿待过并认真搜寻记忆，你不会记得曾路过任何小巷。至少不像那种经典的小巷，可以像火灾逃生梯那样通往两条街道之间，通常最多也就是那种名义上的装货
dog right right I can't specifically remember one you're right but it seems amazing to me right but like proper Allie's they're just they're just not there huh so why do I think there is and then why aren't there Which is the right question right right well so so first why aren't there and and this is because like Which is the right question. Right, right. So first why aren't there? And this is because like when the city planners laid out the grid for Manhattan, north of Houston, street in 1811, something called the commissioners plan, they purposefully did not include allies. They figured that they didn't need allies because they thought the high frequency of the east west streets, which are much closer together to each other than the north south streets, kind of obviated the need for shortcuts or anything else that might break up their wonderfully perfect grid.
平台，对对对，我确实记不清具体有哪条了，你说得对，但这对我来说似乎很神奇，对吧？但真正的小巷，它们就是不存在，对吧？那么为什么我认为有呢？为什么又没有呢？哪个才是正确的问题？对，对。好吧，所以首先为什么没有呢？这是因为，当城市规划者在1811年规划休斯顿街以北的曼哈顿网格时，
But also, and this was probably the real motivation, it was a way to maximize real estate. Because this way, without any alleys cutting through the blocks, the landowners could squeeze in more housing and the land was worth more. And after that, almost no alleys were built because, of course, why own an alley when you can own a larger building? And so the result is that today Manhattan has, at best, a dozen things you might call alleys, but they're all south of Canal Street in the oldest part of the city that was built before the grid.
但同时，这可能才是真正的动机，这也是最大化房地产利益的一种方式。因为通过这种方式，没有小巷切割街区，地主就可以塞进更多住房，土地也就更有价值。在那之后，几乎没有再建造任何小巷，因为废话，既然你可以拥有更大的建筑，谁还会想拥有小巷呢？因此结果就是，如今的曼哈顿充其量只有十几处你可以称之为小巷的东西，但它们全都在运河街以南、网格建成之前的老城区。
Wow, that's amazing. I mean, now that you mention it, the thing I noticed the most when I'm walking on the streets of New York is the piles and piles of trash, which when I lived in Chicago, that's put in the alley, that is not on the street. Chicago is like the antithesis. Chicago has something like 2,000 miles of alley. Totally. And it's just, it's so key to the idea of that city, but in that case, it's actually true. But you know, it's weird. A lot of people don't put this to into together including
哇，太神奇了。我是说，既然你提到了，我在纽约街头行走时最注意到的一件事就是一堆堆的垃圾，而当我住在芝加哥时，垃圾是放在小巷里的，不是在街上。芝加哥简直是反其道而行之。芝加哥有大约2000英里长的小巷。完全是这样。这正是这座城市概念的核心所在，但在那种情况下，这确实是真的。但你知道，这很奇怪。很多人没有把这一点联系起来，包括
new yorkers that the new york alice up evasive that even a lot of native new yorkers have fallen prey to it one of my favorite things to do is just like i always ask people out of fellow new york is interesting like when was last time you remember saying uh... i really get it somewhere in the quickest way to get there would be to take the alley shortcut it's not it's not a thing. It's only when you point it out to them
纽约人，以至于纽约的小巷如此难以捉摸，连很多土生土长的纽约人都深陷其中。我最喜欢做的事情之一就是问别人，作为同胞纽约人，你最后一次记得自己说“哦……我真的要去某个地方，最快的方式就是抄小巷近路”是什么时候？这根本不存在。只有当你向他们指出这一点时，
that they kind of step back and go yeah that's right. So this is Nick Carr and he's a film location scout who worked in New York for many years on films like War of the Worlds, Wolf of Wall Street, or recently The New Ghostbusters, The Smurf's's movie that didn't know that had a man had a section you got to know this of course the smurfs go to new york and you know what that's what happens when when your television shows turned into a it makes sense or at least in the sequel and uh... he says but anyways nick nicks as it this belief that new york has allies is like the bane of his
他们才会退后一步说：“哦，对哦。”这就是尼克·卡尔，他是一位电影外景制片，在纽约工作多年，参与过《世界大战》、《华尔街之狼》，以及最近的《新捉鬼敢死队》、还有那部你可能不知道有曼哈顿部分的《蓝精灵》电影，你必须知道这个，当然了，蓝精灵去了纽约，你知道吗，当你的电视剧变成这样时，这就说得通了，或者至少在续集里是这样，呃……他说，不过不管怎样，尼克说，这种纽约有小巷的信念简直是他的
because hilltell director you know new york new york is not a city of allies new york does not have allies but you were to tell a director that that there are no allies in new york if they'll look at you like you have to head and think that you don't know how to do your job so invariably he reluctantly winds up
噩梦，因为他会告诉导演，你知道的，纽约、纽约不是一个充满小巷的城市，纽约没有小巷。但如果你告诉导演纽约没有小巷，他们看你的眼神就会像看一个长了两颗头的人一样，觉得你根本不知道怎么工作。所以毫无例外地，他只能勉强
showing them the dozen or so allys south of canals three and i would think of the filmable allies in New York that look like how you want them to look. I'd say it's like five or six. And of those five or six, most of them are either privately owned and so they're very expensive to shoot in or they have other permanent issues, logistical constraints, parking constraints, leaving only this one alley just south of Canal Street and east of Broadway in which almost everyone films. And that is Cortland alley which is just it is the alley. And Cortland you have to understand this it's the alley you've been seeing your entire life. You just don't realize it. So, like, let me show you some photos. It's got the fire escapes.
带他们去看运河街以南那十几条小巷，如果要我想象纽约那些看起来符合你期望的电影化小巷，我可以说也就五六条吧。在这五六条中，大多数要么是私有产权，所以拍摄成本非常高，要么有其他永久性的问题、后勤限制、停车限制，只剩下运河街以南、百老汇以东的这一条巷子，几乎所有人都在那里拍摄。那就是科特兰巷（Cortlandt Alley），它就是那条巷子。关于科特兰巷，你必须明白，你一辈子都在看这条巷子。你只是没有意识到而已。所以，让我给你看一些照片。它有消防楼梯。
It's got loading docs. It's got bricks and graffiti. And it's an alley. Really is. It is like the perfect alley. It's very archetypal. This is the photo. This is the one where I looked at it.
它有装货台。它有砖墙和涂鸦。它就是一条小巷。确实如此。它就像是一条完美的小巷。非常具有原型代表性。就是这张照片。这就是我看了之后觉得
I have totally seen that. Yeah. I've seen 300 lawn orroofs with that alley. Yeah, I have totally seen that. Yeah, I've seen 300 lawn orph so it's with that, Ali. Yeah, exactly. And yeah, it's so archetypical to such a degree that if you walked by it, you wouldn't actually notice it because it would feel so intensely normal. It's almost like you'd been there, you know, like even if you'd never set foot in it, take it for granted because you have already been there.
我绝对见过这个。对。我在《法律与秩序》里看过三百次这条巷子。对，我绝对见过这个。对，我在《法律与秩序》里看过三百次这条巷子。对，没错。而且是的，它太具有原型代表性了，以至于如果你从它旁边走过，你其实不会注意到它，因为它会显得如此强烈地自然。就好像你去过那里一样，你知道的，即使你从未踏足其中，你也会把它当作理所当然，因为你已经去过那里了。
So I'm pretty sure that whenever the first time i said i walk down that alley it might as well have been like the hundredth time i walk down that alley but here's where things get especially weird because the reason courtman looks like the platonic ideal of a new york alley is precisely because it's been used in so many movies and so there's this chicken and anything that happens where once a filmmaker who wants to film a quote unquote classic new york alice c's courtland
所以我敢肯定，无论我第一次走过那条巷子的时候是什么感觉，它都可能就像我第一百次走过那条巷子一样。但接下来事情变得格外诡异，因为科特兰巷之所以看起来像是纽约小巷的柏拉图式理想形态，恰恰是因为它在太多电影中被使用过，所以这里存在一种鸡生蛋蛋生鸡的现象。一旦想要拍摄所谓的“经典纽约小巷”场景的电影制作人看到了科特兰巷，
they're like this is perfect and it lurs them into contributing to this fantasy of new york because when a director has a location in mind he is created the perfect location and that and no location you ever find will ever match up to what it is right but courtland is what you picture the director pictures it and it's not eighty percent of the way there's not ninety it's a hundred percent of what he had in mind and that's because the people directors see a version of new york and other movies and t-v-shows and then go
他们就会觉得“这太完美了”，而这又诱使他们继续延续这种纽约的幻想，因为当一个导演心中有了某个外景地，他就会创造出完美的地点，而你找到的任何外景地都永远无法与之匹敌，对吧？但科特兰巷就是你脑海中想象的、导演脑海中想象的那个样子，它不是完成度百分之八十，也不是百分之九十，它百分之百符合他心中的构想。这是因为导演们从其他电影和电视节目中看到了某种版本的纽约，然后当他们在城里拍自己的电影时，就想去
and want to recreate it when they do their own film in town so the sad truth is that uh... it's sort of a stereotype that gets perpetuated from movie to movie. And so now, Kortlyn is forever caught in this loop. To the point where it can seem like it's all it's used for is filming by basically everyone all the time. When I used to drive by, I mean, I swear to God, it was on a weekly basis.
重现它。所以残酷的真相是，呃……这是一种在电影之间不断延续的刻板印象。因此，如今，科特兰巷永远陷入了这个循环中。以至于它看起来几乎成了基本上所有人随时随地用来拍摄的全部外景。我以前开车路过时，说实话，我发誓，几乎每周都能看到。
The Law and Order series would put a body in the alley every other week, but the thing is they all did it. They all do it and still do it. Every, every major crime show, cop show, superhero show, anything that is filmed in New York has filmed in Portland. Like I would say that with 100% confidence. So like even the one alley in Manhattan doesn't really function as an alley, it's basically a film set. Yeah, exactly. And just to give you an idea of Hollywood's,
《法律与秩序》系列每隔一周就会把一具尸体放在这条巷子里，但问题是他们全都这么做。他们过去这样做，现在也依然这样做。每一个、每一个主要的犯罪剧、警匪剧、超级英雄剧，任何在纽约拍摄的剧集都在科特兰巷拍过。我可以百分之百自信地这么说。所以，即使是曼哈顿唯一的一条小巷，也没有真正作为小巷发挥作用，它基本上就是一个电影布景。对，没错。为了让你了解好莱坞对
like to the greedy, which it's like treated as a film set, and Hollywood's zeal in pursuit of the platonic New York alley, like a story often calls for an alley to be filled with trash. That's a part of the classic concept since that's part of the archetype. But of course, real trash and grime would be hazardous to the casting crew so the first thing they do is actually clean the alley with like pressure hoses to the point where it's you
这种“贪婪”的追求，它被当作电影布景，好莱坞对追求柏拉图式纽约小巷的热情，往往要求小巷里堆满垃圾。这是经典概念的一部分，因为这是原型的一部分。但是，当然，真正的垃圾和污垢会对演员和剧组造成危险，所以他们要做的第一件事其实是用高压水枪清洗小巷，直到它
know pristine and then you buy movie trash and movie trash is large plastic bags like trash bags that are filled with approved logo sort of trash so it's like generic milk bottles and cereal boxes but i believe each bag of movie trash is about forty to sixty dollars a bag uh... so there's an industry just in making allies look like uh... look like allies but what especially kind of interest me about all this is that i think with some cities
你知道的，一尘不染，然后你购买电影垃圾，电影垃圾就是装满了经批准带有特定标志的垃圾的大塑料袋，所以里面装的是普通的牛奶瓶和麦片盒，但我相信每一袋电影垃圾大约要四十到六十美元，呃……所以存在这样一个专门让小巷看起来像……看起来像小巷的行业。但关于这一切，最让我感兴趣的是，我认为对于某些城市，
we don't really know much about them so they get to be their own thing. There might be like cliches about San Francisco or Chicago, but no one outside of San Francisco like truly thinks they know the city. But New York, perhaps more than any other city, in some sense, it belongs to everyone. Everyone feels that they know it.
我们对它们了解不多，所以它们能够保持自身的独特性。关于旧金山或芝加哥可能会有一些陈词滥调，但旧金山以外没有人真正觉得自己了解这座城市。但纽约，或许比任何其他城市都更甚，在某种意义上，它属于每个人。每个人都觉得自己了解它。
Right, because they've seen it in a million movies, it is like America's city to so many people. And it is the city to so many people in another cell. Right, and there's like a level granularity when you talk about uptown, downtown, so Manhattan Bridge, Brooklyn Bridge, Brooklyn, like, like, there are more like household names in terms of like the geography. Totally. No, that makes sense. It's also kind of like, you know, people think they know it, but they don't. And the result is that at some point the idea of New York
对，因为他们在数百万部电影中看过它，对许多人来说，它就像是美国的城市。而且对另一些人来说，它就是这座城市。对，当你谈到上城、下城、曼哈顿大桥、布鲁克林大桥、布鲁克林时，有一种颗粒度，就地理而言，有更多家喻户晓的名字。完全是这样。不，这说得通。这也像是，你知道的，人们以为自己了解它，但其实并不了解。结果就是，在某个时刻，关于纽约的想法
has overtaken the reality of New York. It kind of takes cultural precedent, right? Even in the minds of a lot of New Yorkers who never realize New York has no allies. And it's just sad because it's almost like an actor that's typecast, right? Like it's like an actor that's being asked to play the same old role because hey you did
压倒了纽约的现实。它在文化上占据了优先地位，对吧？甚至在许多从未意识到纽约没有小巷的纽约人心中也是如此。这真的很可悲，因为它几乎就像是一个被定型化的演员，对吧？就像一个演员被要求一遍又听地扮演同一个老角色，因为“嘿，你在1977年时把那个角色演得太棒了，所以再继续演个五十来年吧”……而且我认为，当你如实描绘特色外景、让它们成为真正的角色而不仅仅是背景时，电影要有趣得多。
that one role really really well back in nineteen seventy seven so keep doing it for another you know fifty years uh... and i think just think movies are just so much more interesting when you pray portray uh... the locations featured on for what they are and let them be a real character instead of just a backdrop so at at any point in its film history, was it ever named or presented as Corland Alley? Almost never.
那么在它的电影史上的任何时候，它曾被命名或呈现为科特兰巷吗？几乎从不。
Like, but Nick says like, men in black three has a scene where Will Smith is tracking down an alien and they actually do at least attempt to They did their best. I think that's the most you can ask of Minim Black III. Well, thanks so much, Joe. Thank you, Roman. This is so cool. This is been a lot of fun. Okay, Sean.
就像尼克说的，《黑衣人3》里有一个威尔·史密斯追踪外星人的场景，他们至少尝试过去做这件事。他们尽力了。我想这是你能对《黑衣人3》的最大要求了。好吧，非常感谢你，乔。谢谢你，罗曼。这太酷了。这真的很有趣。好的，肖恩。
Composer, Sean Real. What's the story of today? Well, first, I want to ask you a question, Roman, so you've never done karaoke. I've never done karaoke. How is that possible? I've played the singing parts of Guitar Hero. That's almost karaoke. Almost.
作曲家肖恩·雷尔。今天的故事是什么？好吧，首先，我想问你一个问题，罗曼，你从来没有唱过卡拉OK。我从来没唱过卡拉OK。这怎么可能？我玩过《吉他英雄》里的唱歌部分。那几乎算是卡拉OK。差不多吧。
But not as performative within a bar with strangers. I've never done that. Yeah. It doesn't count. That's fair. So I want to tell you about the person who invented the karaoke machine. Oh. His name is Daisuke Inoue.
但不是在酒吧里和陌生人一起那种表演性的。我从没做过那种。对。那不算数。倒也是。那我想跟你讲讲发明卡拉OK机器的那个人。哦。他的名字叫井上大佑。
And as you can imagine, he loves music. Of course. I read this interview with him and I found out that he started working as a drummer when he was still a teenager in high school. And after he graduated, he was perpetually in a traveling band that did cap-a-ray music for nine years. And I think that's a really big achievement, but in his interview, he likes to kind of talk smack on himself. And so he says, when I realized that no matter how much
你可以想象，他非常热爱音乐。当然。我读过一篇关于他的采访，我发现他在高中还是个青少年的时候就开始做鼓手了。毕业后，他长期在一个巡回乐队里，连续九年演奏卡巴莱（Cabaret）音乐。我认为这是一个了不起的成就，但在采访中，他喜欢自嘲。所以他说，当意识到无论我怎么努力练习，
I practiced, I could never be as good as someone with God-given talent. And that was enough to change my life as a band man. And after nine years on the road, many tales and no regrets I went home. I don't know. It seemed like it was more than just his musicianship that took him out of road life. It seems like he wasn't really compensated fairly all the time. And people, he was working with, they were really, they partied a lot and they're drinking all their money away. So he was 28 and living with his parents in Kobe, Japan after all that. Wow. And so 1968, karaoke is kind of already like a social activity, but it's done with
我也永远无法达到那些拥有天赋之人的水平时，这就足以改变我作为乐队成员的生活了。在路上漂泊了九年，经历了许多故事、没有遗憾后，我回家了。我不知道。感觉除了他的音乐才华之外，还有其他原因让他退出了巡演生活。似乎他的报酬并没有一直得到公平对待。而且他一起工作的人，他们经常聚会，把所有的钱都喝酒花光了。所以在经历了这一切之后，他28岁了，和父母一起住在日本神户。哇。所以在1968年，卡拉OK其实已经是一种社交活动了，但它是用
live instruments. So they're like bars where you have a musician playing a single guitar or a keyboard or something and people singing along to the hits. And this was one of Daisuke's regular gigs when he was living there with his parents. And he says, playing the drums? Oh no, he learned how to play keyboard.
现场乐器来完成的。所以有一些酒吧，里面有音乐家弹奏单吉他、键盘之类的乐器，大家跟着热门歌曲一起唱歌。这就是井上大佑和父母住在一起时经常驻唱的 gigs（演出）之一。你是说打鼓？哦不，他学会了弹键盘。
Oh, okay. Yeah, he says that he taught himself 300 songs, which once again, it is just like a humble brag Because then he says because then he goes on to say that he was like but every time I tried to learn more than 300 songs Like I just would forget them or I would start mixing them up Wow, so yeah, dice case is pretty down on himself Okay, I find it really charming is pretty down on himself. Yeah, we're guy.
哦，好吧。是的，他说他自学了300首歌，这又一次，就像是一种谦虚的炫耀，因为接着他说，因为随后他又说，每当我试图学超过300首歌时，我就把它们忘光了，或者开始把它们弄混。哇，所以是的，大佑对自己要求挺严格的。好吧，我发现这真的很迷人。对自己挺严格的。是的，真是个好人。
Okay, I find it really charming. So he's working at these karaoke bars, and he's got like a bunch of regular karaoke singers, and there was this one business man who would always sing with him, who kind of changed everything. This businessman was about to travel for work, and he wanted to be able to sing for his colleagues
好吧，我发现这真的很迷人。所以他在这些卡拉OK酒吧工作，他有一群固定的卡拉OK歌手，其中有一个商人总是和他一起唱歌，这个人可以说是改变了一切。这位商人即将出差，他希望在旅途中能够为同事们唱歌，
on the trip, and Dicek ever calls the businessman saying to him, your keyboard playing is the only music I can sing to. You know how my voice is and you know what it needs to sound good. And Daisuke couldn't take time off work so he taped himself playing some of this guy's favorite songs. And it worked. The guy was happy. Daisuke got paid. And I'm sure you can see where this is going. Totally. After his success with this businessman, Dysuke in 1971 commissioned a friend to build a machine out of three existing machines and amplifier, a coin box, and an eight-track car stereo.
井上大佑回忆说，这位商人对他说：“你的键盘演奏是我唯一能跟着唱歌的音乐。你知道我的声音是什么样的，也知道它需要什么才能听起来很好听。”而井上大佑抽不出时间休假，于是他录下了自己弹奏这家伙最喜欢的一些歌曲的磁带。这招真管用。那家伙很高兴。井上大佑拿到了报酬。我敢肯定你能看出这要走向何方。完全是这样。在与这位商人的成功合作之后，1971年，井上大佑委托一位朋友用三台现有的机器组装了一台机器：一个放大器、一个投币盒和一个八轨汽车立体声音响。
And he called it the Juke Eight. So a hundred yen, you put in a hundred yen, and the machine would turn on for five minutes. So you could put on a tape of instrumental music and sing through a microphone. And Roman, I want you to see one of these machines. They're really beautiful. If you just go into Slack.
他把它叫做 Juke Eight（点唱八轨机）。投入一百日元，你投入一百日元，机器就会启动五分钟。这样你就可以播放一盘器乐磁带，然后通过麦克风唱歌。罗曼，我想让你看一台这样的机器。它们真的很漂亮。如果你看一下 Slack。
Oh, wow. It really is beautiful. Yeah. It's a cabinet, it's red and white. It has great little analog knobs and a place for the, you know, the A-Track cassette, what I would call a cart machine in the radio business that you press in there, and then a little red cabinet on the right that stores a little library of A-Track tapes. It's lovely. Is that him smiling right next to him? Yeah. What a delightful looking man.
哦，哇。它真的很漂亮。是的。它是一个红白相间的机柜。它有很棒的小模拟旋钮，还有放置那个，你知道的，八轨盒式磁带的地方——在广播行业里我称之为卡式机器，你把它按进去，右边还有一个红色的小柜子，里面存放着一小叠八轨磁带。太可爱了。紧挨着它的那个笑得很开心的人是他吗？是的。看起来多讨人喜欢的男士啊。
And every picture he's smiling like that. I love it. So the music on these first A-track tapes, were they the ones that did he compose those? Or how did he get the music for those? So they were popular songs and Dixie recorded them with his band or actually I guess he recorded his band playing the songs. He says that early on in the process, they fired him from playing.
而且每一张照片他都笑得那么开心。我太喜欢了。那么这些第一批八轨磁带上的音乐，是他们制作的吗？还是他自己作曲的？或者他是怎么弄到这些音乐的？所以这些都是流行歌曲，井上大佑和他的乐队一起录制的，或者其实我想是他录制了乐队演奏这些歌曲。他说在录制过程的早期，乐队就把他开除了。
Sorry, Hitch. Again, poor dice kick. Poor guy. So he just focused on recording and mixing the music, which is a really important part. Oh, totally. Totally. Yeah, if it doesn't get recorded, no karaoke machine. Yeah. Yeah, recording and mixing, thank you, Sharif. Thank you, Roman. Sharif does the really best job with it, for sure. Yeah, and it's funny to me because even though Daisuke was fired from his own band, he was a real hustler.
抱歉，大佑。又来了，可怜的大佑。可怜的人。所以他只专注于录音和混音，这是非常重要的一部分。哦，完全是这样。完全是这样。是的，如果没有录音，就没有卡拉OK机器。是的。是的，录音和混音，谢谢谢里夫。谢谢罗曼。谢里夫在这方面绝对做得最棒。是的，这对我来说很有趣，因为尽管井上大佑被自己的乐队开除了，但他是个真正有拼劲的人。
He got bars all over Kobe to lease these machines from him. He got contracts with major record labels to use all these popular songs. But he didn't patent the machine. Oh no, yeah. He says, when I first made the juke-aids, a brother-un-loss suggested I take out a patent,
他让神户各地的酒吧向他租用这些机器。他与各大唱片公司签了合同，以使用所有这些流行歌曲。但他没有为这台机器申请专利。哦不，是的。他说，当我第一次制作 Juke Eight 时，我的一位大舅子建议我申请专利，
but at the time, I didn't think anything would come of it. I was just hoping the drinking places in the Kobe area would use my machine. Most people don't believe me when I say this, but I don't think karaoke would have taken off like it did if there had been a patent on the first machine. I think that's actually a pretty fair assessment. Yeah.
但在当时，我并不认为这能成什么气候。我只是希望神户地区的饮酒场所能使用我的机器。大多数人听到这话都不相信我，但我认为，如果最初的机器申请了专利，卡拉OK绝对不会像后来那样风靡。我认为这其实是一个相当公允的评价。是的。
Honestly, you know, it's a really nice and joyful thing even though I've never participated in it. It's a nice and joyful thing. A lot of people think so, yeah. And this machine is really, really lovely and And it's actually nice to think of it. Is it just existing in the world to make the world better and not necessarily to make him that money? No, yeah.
老实说，你知道的，这是一件非常美好和快乐的事情，尽管我从未参与其中。这是一件美好且充满快乐的事情。很多人都这么认为，是的。而且这台机器真的非常非常可爱，而且想到它存在于世上是为了让世界变得更好，而不一定是为了给他赚大钱，其实感觉挺好的。不，是的。
It does make some people money. This other person did take out a patent on a laser-discarriotie machine. Oh God. But he's not part of this story. No, God no. Let's write him out of history. Yeah.
它确实给一些人赚了钱。另一个人确实为激光视盘卡拉OK机申请了专利。天哪。但他不是这个故事的一部分。不，天哪。让我们把他从历史中抹去吧。是的。
But then, then, a dice-gate goes on. Besides, I didn't build the thing from scratch. The amp, the microphone, let's write him out of history. Yeah. But then a day skate goes on. Besides, I didn't build the thing from scratch. The amp, the microphone, the A-track player, even the 100-yen box machine, all had patents on them. Yeah, but that's not how patents work. Could have totally gotten a patent for it. You think so? Totally.
但是随后，随后，大佑继续说道。再说一次，我并不是从零开始制造这台机器的。放大器、麦克风、八轨播放器，让我们把他从历史中抹去吧。是的。但是大佑接着说。再说一次，我并不是从零开始制造这台机器的。放大器、麦克风、八轨播放器，甚至一百日元的投币箱，这些都有专利。是的，但专利不是这么运作的。他完全可以为此申请专利。你觉得呢？完全可以。
Yeah, I don't know anything about patent law. Especially Japanese patent law. Well, I don't know about Japanese patent law. I actually have no expert of US patent law. Well, I don't know about Japanese patent law and I actually have no expert of US patent law but if you come up with a new use for even a known thing and prescribe that use inside of the patent it doesn't have to be three machines it could be one machine to do a certain thing as long as you change a little something and change it's purpose so he totally had the right to a patent for sure. So this is just more of him talking smack on himself But yeah, what I really love about this story on a whole
是的，我对专利法一无所知。尤其是日本专利法。好吧，我对日本专利法一无所知。实际上我也不是美国专利法的专家。好吧，我对日本专利法一无所知，而且实际上我我也不是美国专利法专家，但如果你为即使是一个已知的事物想出了一种新的用途，并在专利中规定了这种用途，它不一定需要是三台机器，它可以是一台用来做特定事情的机器，只要你稍微改变一点东西并改变它的用途，所以他绝对有权利申请专利。所以这只是他在自我调侃。不过是的，我真正喜欢这个故事的整体地方在于
is that he seems pretty okay with how all of this turned out. You know, he talks a lot about just like how glad he is that this brought so much joy into the world. And he says, I may not have the original patent. Some say I would have made $80 million last year and that was a bad year. But I have good friends and a family I love, and I can't help but smile every day.
他似乎对这一切的结果感到挺满意的。你知道的，他经常谈到自己很高兴这为世界带来了如此多的欢乐。他说，我可能没有最初的专利。有人说我去年能赚8000万美元，而那还是糟糕的一年。但我有好的朋友和深爱的家人，我每天都忍不住微笑。
Do you have a thing to some uppers? Yeah, I guess the last thing was I just wanted to say that DiceKey says that to honor Karaoke, he and his wife and daughter and three granddaughters get out a song book once a week and see who can sing the most songs before going horse. Which sounds crazy.
你有什么要补充的吗？对，我想说的最后一件事是，大佑说为了纪念卡拉OK，他和妻子、女儿以及三个孙女每周都会拿出一本歌本，看看谁能在唱到嗓子沙哑之前唱最多的歌。听起来太疯狂了。
That's so crazy. That's way harder than I want a party. And yeah, and there's more to his story, but I think it's better told from him, so we'll put a link to that on our website. Nice. Alright, thanks. Yeah. And we should totally go carry out getting some time.
太疯狂了。这比我想象的派对还要硬核。是的，他的故事还有更多内容，但我想由他自己来讲会更好，所以我们会在我们的网站上放一个链接。太好了。好的，谢谢。好的。我们真该找个时间去唱卡拉OK。
Totally. I think we could make that up. Thanks. Thanks, Fromm. About a year ago, our senior editor, Delaney Hall, moved from beautiful downtown Oakland, California back to New Mexico, where she grew up. She now works for Nine Nymphia remotely, and her mini story is about this phenomenon in the new city where she lives, which is Santa Fe.
完全可以。我想我们可以安排。谢谢。谢谢罗曼。大约一年前，我们的资深编辑德兰妮·霍尔从美丽繁华的加州奥克兰市中心搬回了她长大的新墨西哥州。她现在为99%隐形进行远程工作，她的迷你故事讲述了她现在居住的新城圣达菲的一种现象。
The phenomenon is called Zozobra. Zozobra is a big deal here in Santa Fe. Basically, every year, a group of people in the city build this enormous marionette that's named Sosobra. And in Spanish, Sosobra means anxiety. So he's like all of the city's collective sorrows embodied in this huge puppet. Wow, that's amazing. So what does he, what does he look like? Well, he's 50 feet tall. He is dressed in a long white gown. He has these very dark angry eyes. They're usually rimmed with green or black. And what happens is that every fall this group constructs a news ozobra and about 50,000
这种现象被称为佐佐布拉（Zozobra）。佐佐布拉在圣达菲是一件大事。基本上，每年城里的一群人都会制作这个巨大的傀儡，名叫佐佐布拉。在西班牙语中，佐佐布拉的意思是焦虑。所以他就像是这座城市所有集体悲伤在这个巨大傀儡身上的实体化。哇，太神奇了。那么他、他长什么样？好吧，他有50英尺高。他穿着一件长长的白袍。他有着非常黑暗愤怒的眼睛。眼眶通常描着绿色或黑色。发生的事情是，每年秋天，这群人都建造一个新的佐佐布拉，大约有5万
people gather in one of Santa Fe's biggest parks and they burn him. Wow, they burn him a 50 foot puppet. Yeah, it's a very intense kind of pagan feeling event. I mean, basically the crowd chance, burn him, burn him, burn him, and he's set on fire, and he is slowly engulfed in flames. And I assume they burn him so they can burn their collective anxiety that he represents. Yeah, yeah, exactly. So because he represents Glim, it's this way that the city purges its sadness every year. And people get to participate in these interesting ways.
人聚集在圣达菲最大的公园之一，然后把他烧掉。哇，他们烧掉他，一个50英尺高的傀儡。是的，这是一场感觉非常强烈、带有某种异教色彩的活动。我是说，基本上人群会高喊“烧死他，烧死他，烧死他”，然后他被点燃，慢慢被烈火吞噬。我猜他们烧他是为了烧掉他所代表的集体焦虑。是的，是的，完全正确。因为他代表着阴霾，这是这座城市每年净化悲伤的一种方式。人们以这些有趣的方式参与其中。
And one of the reasons, so so-but-a, is so flammable, is that he is stuffed with bushels of shredded paper. And where that paper comes from is in the weeks leading up to the burning, anyone with an excess of gloom is encouraged to sort of write down their gloomy thoughts on a piece of paper and to leave it in this thing called the gloom box, which at least in the past has been located in the offices of one of the local newspapers. So people contribute police reports and mortgage documents and divorce papers.
佐佐布拉之所以如此易燃，原因之一是他塞满了大捆大捆的碎纸。这些纸的来源是，在焚烧前的几周里，任何心中郁闷过盛的人都被鼓励把他们忧郁的想法写在一张纸上，然后投进一个叫“忧郁盒”（gloom box）的东西里，过去这个盒子至少曾放在当地一家报纸的办公室里。所以人们会投入警察报告、抵押文件和离婚协议书。
I mean, just anything they might want to burn. It reminds me of other sort of bonfire rituals, like burning man or something in which a lot of people go to around here. Yeah, I mean, so so it has been around a lot longer than burning man. It's been around since the 1920s, but there are definitely some similarities, like both were developed by artists. Both events began relatively small, like in someone's backyard
我是说，任何他们想要烧掉的东西。这让我想起其他一些篝火仪式，比如火人节（Burning Man）之类的，这里很多人都会去。是的，我是说，佐佐布拉的历史比火人节悠久得多。它从20世纪20年代就开始有了，但确实有一些相似之处，比如两者都是由艺术家发起的。两项活动最初规模都相对较小，比如在某人的后院
around a beach, and then grew into something much bigger. And both actually draw on other traditions that go back even farther. But one thing that's pretty neat about Sosobra is that because he's a puppet, he's capable of kind of rudimentary movement. So his arm swing around, his jaw is hinged, so his mouth opens and closes, and he also makes sound. So I'm going to play a little bit of sound of the event so you can hear it. Oh! Oh! Oh!
围绕着篝火，然后逐渐发展成更大的规模。两者实际上都借鉴了更早的传统。但关于佐佐布拉，一个挺酷的事情是，因为他是个傀儡，他能够做出某种初级的动作。所以他的手臂会四处挥舞，他的下巴有铰链，所以他的嘴巴会开合，他还会发出声音。所以我要播放一点现场的声音，让你们听听。哦！哦！哦！
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh!
哦！哦！哦！哦！哦！哦！哦！哦！
And I assume he's flailing at the same time. Yeah, he's flailing. His mouth is opening and closing. It's a really, it's actually a really troubling event to go to as a kid. It is sort of seared into my memory, but this is actually like the thing I most warm and tell you about because I recently learned just
我猜他在同时胡乱挥舞。是的，他在挥舞。他的嘴巴在一张一合。作为小孩子去参加这个活动，其实是一次非常令人不安的经历。这深深烙印在我的记忆中，但这其实是我最想跟你讲的事情，因为我最近——就在过去一年左右——才了解到，佐佐布拉的声音是现场表演的。而且有一个人，佐佐布拉的声音是现场表演的。有一个人
in the past year or so that the voice of So Sobda is performed live. And there is one guy who's, that the voice of Susoba is performed live. And there is one guy who's been doing the voice for about 20 years. And I learned this thanks to this gem of local reporting from KOT, Action 7 News. Me, I see him as an old grumpy old man. And that's the character that I get into. This is this is Oprah, you know. They want to get rid of him, they want to destroy him, they want to burn him. And my, the way I play the character is I'm fighting to stay alive. On Friday, Michael Ellis will take on the persona of our collective sorrow for the 19th
已经为这个声音配音大约20年了。我了解到这一点，要归功于KOAT行动7新闻（Action 7 News）当地报道的这块瑰宝。在我眼里，他是一个脾气暴躁的老头。这就是我进入的角色。这就是佐佐布拉，你知道的。他们想除掉他，他们想消灭他，他们想烧死他。而我，我诠释这个角色的方式是我在挣扎着求生。周五，迈克尔·埃利斯（Michael Ellis）将第19次
time. And despite the title of Old Man Gloom, Zezorba's voice battles several emotions. There are times when, uh, when he'll sound like he's crying. Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr Adam it. I'm not gonna let you do this to me again. Oh Ellis has the audience of 50,000 should always know what's his over. It's feeling not only do I want the crowd to hear him I want them to feel him and even after 19 years for Alice the big night is always exciting I'll sit down and have a sandwich in the early afternoon After that I've got butterflies and I won't have anything until after it's all over. On Friday night, those butterflies
承担起我们集体悲伤的化身。尽管顶着“忧郁老人”的称号，佐佐布拉的声音还是流露出多种情绪。有时候，呃，他听起来会像是在哭泣。不！我不会让你再对我这么做了！哦！埃利斯认为，5万名观众应该始终明白佐佐布拉的感受。不仅要让观众听到他的声音，还要让他们感受到。即使过了19年，对埃利斯来说，这个盛大的夜晚总是令人兴奋的。我会在下午早些时候坐下来吃个三明治。在那之后，我就开始心神不定，直到一切结束之前我什么都不会吃。周五晚上，这些焦虑
join all of New Mexico's gloom up in smoke. Yeah, I just I love this new clip so much. I think it's one of my favorites ever and it's it's the combination of the reporter's seriousness or maybe mock seriousness and then just like the sublime ridiculousness of what you're seeing, which of course people can't see it, but to describe it, it's Michael Ellis, the voice of Susoba, performing the sounds of Susoba,
将伴随着新墨西哥州所有的阴霾一同化为青烟。是的，我太喜欢这段新闻剪辑了。我认为这是我最喜欢的片段之一，它结合了记者的严肃性（或者说假装的严肃），以及你所看到的场景那崇高而又荒诞的特质——当然人们看不到它，但如果描述一下的话，就是迈克尔·埃利斯（佐佐布拉的声音扮演者）正在表演佐佐布拉的声音，
but to this big empty baseball field, which, you know, probably later in the night will be filled with 50,000, 60,000 screaming people, but but at the moment is just entirely empty. Um, yeah. you get like a little taste of what Michael Ellis is about, but what is he really like? Yeah, so this was the only thing I could find on the internet about him. And from seeing this clip, I definitely wanted to learn more. And so I looked him up and went to talk with him. And what I learned is that he was born and raised in Santa Fe. And so Michael told me that, you know, as a kid, so sober was like this figure, this monster who almost seemed real, like actually alive. And that sense of realness was this thing that the community continues to really play into and cultivate. Growing up, I remember there would be little stories in the newspaper talking about how Zizobra has been spotted in the royals in the east side of town.
但面对的是一个巨大的空旷棒球场，你知道的，可能在当晚晚些时候这里会挤满5万、6万名尖叫的人，但在这一刻它完全是空的。嗯，是的。你对迈克尔·埃利斯有了一点了解，但他到底是个什么样的人呢？是的，所以在互联网上我只能找到关于他的这些。从这个剪辑中，我绝对想了解更多。所以我查了他的资料并去和他交谈。我了解到的是他在圣达菲出生长大。迈克尔告诉我，你知道的，作为小孩子，佐佐布拉就像是这样一个形象，一个几乎看起来真实存在的怪物，就好像真的活着一样。而这种真实感是社区继续努力营造和培养的东西。在成长过程中，我记得报纸上会有一些小报道，谈到佐佐布拉在城东的干涸河床（arroyos）被发现。
And you would hear stories of sheep being missing from the area. Little things like that would play into trying to make this thing seem real. And so from there, how did Michael actually become the voice of Zazobra? So as a high schooler, he started volunteering for the event. He would help with building the puppet, stuff like that, and he just kept being involved a little more each year. And eventually, he was asked if he wanted to help with the voice. So it was just sort of a matter of hanging around for long enough, I guess. And so did Michael do it any differently?
你会听到该地区有绵羊失踪的故事。诸如此类的小事情都在为让这个东西看起来真实而服务。那么从那以后，迈克尔是怎么真正成为佐佐布拉的声音的呢？所以作为一名高中生，他开始为这项活动做志愿者。他会帮忙制作傀儡之类的东西，而且他每年都让自己更多地参与其中一点。最后，有人问他是否想帮忙配音。所以我想这只是一种在周围待得足够久的结果。那么迈克尔有做得很不一样吗？
Did he add something special to the voice when he took over? Michael didn't have any formal voice acting experience. He's done various jobs throughout his life, including working at Lowe's Hardware and running a DJ business. But he told me that the main thing he wanted to bring to Susoba was that sense of realness, that kind of aliveness that I was talking about earlier. And to do that, he said he had to find ways
当他接手时，他给这个声音增添了什么特别的东西吗？迈克尔没有任何正式的配音经验。他在生活中做过各种工作，包括在劳氏五金店（Lowe's Hardware）工作和经营DJ业务。但他告诉我，他想给佐佐布拉带来的主要东西是那种真实感，那种我之前谈到的仿佛有生命力的感觉。为了做到这一点，他说他必须寻找方法
to really empathize with Susoba, this grumpy old man, and to see the whole event unfolding from his perspective. Knowing that everybody wants his demise, they want to see it happen. So I do my best to try to fight with just, you know, with my voice. There are times when it'll almost sound like he's crying. When he begins to realize that there isn't anything he's going to be able to do to stop it. Of course, in our conversation I was like pushing to try to understand is there some deep gloomy memory or experience that Michael taps into in order to perform. I asked him about his personal history.
真正去同情佐佐布拉这个脾气暴躁的老头，并从他的视角看待整场活动的展开。知道每个人都渴望他的消亡，他们都想看到这一切发生。所以我尽我所能只用我的声音去抗争。有时候他听起来几乎像是在哭泣。当他开始意识到自己无法做任何事情来阻止这一切时。当然，在我们的对话中，我一直在追问，试图了解迈克尔在表演时是否会触及什么深沉阴郁的记忆或经历。我问了他关于他个人历史的问题。
I asked him about some health problems he's had recently. But he said, you know, not really. It just comes when it's needed. You just got the readily accessible grumpy old man right there. I guess. Maybe there's a little bit of that deep inside. So that's the voice of Susobeda. And I really like thinking about the fact that when I went to see Susobeda burn back in the 80s, it was Michael performing the voice. And if I take Fiona and my daughter next year
我问了他一些最近遇到的健康问题。但他说，其实没有啦。需要的时候它自然就会来。你随时都能找到一个现成的、脾气暴躁的老头。我想是的。也许内心深处确实有一点点那种特质。这就是苏索贝达的声音。我真的很喜欢回想这样一件事：当年我在80年代去看苏索贝达燃烧时，演这个角色的正是迈克尔。如果明年我带着菲奥娜和我的女儿去
that it will probably be Michael again. Up next is our technical producer Sharif Yusuf All right, so Roman if I told you that I had another map story How excited would you be? Very excited. Okay, cool. I love a good map story. Oh, I know so maybe Maybe if you could just go to Google maps real quick So maybe if you could just go to Google Maps real quick. The main thing we're going to be looking at today is the border between the US and Canada and pardon my cibolins, I have some dental work. Okay, yeah.
那大概还会是迈克尔。接下来是我们的技术制片人谢里夫·优素福。好吧，罗曼，如果我告诉你我还有另一个关于地图的故事，你会有多兴奋？非常兴奋。好吧，酷。我喜欢精彩的地图故事。哦，我知道，所以也许——如果你能快速打开谷歌地图的话——所以也许如果你能快速打开谷歌地图。我们今天主要要看的是美国和加拿大的边境，请原谅我的发音，我刚做完牙科手术。好吧，行。
You're excused. Thank you. And the thing they need to pay attention to is the 49th parallel in the Pacific Northwest of America. Okay. So important thing to be here. Okay. yeah. And you can like, probably,
不用不好意思。谢谢。我们需要关注的地方是美国太平洋西北部的北纬49度线。好的。这里有个很重要的东西。好吧。行。而且你可能——
maybe now can notice a little something that looks off. Are you talking about point Roberts, that sticks out right here. Yeah, point Roberts on that little peninsula, so Watson Peninsula. Maybe you can just sort of describe what you're seeing. So point Roberts is off of peninsula, off of the area of Vancouver. It looks like it's completely cut off from very, very gritted streets. Yeah. A couple.
现在大概能注意到有点不对劲的地方。你是在说突出来的罗伯茨角吗？对，就是突在这里的罗伯茨角。是的，罗伯茨角在这个小半岛上，也就是沃森半岛。也许你可以描述一下你看到的情景。所以罗伯茨角是一个半岛，位于温哥华地区外围。它看起来像是被完全切断了，有着非常非常整齐的网格状街道。对。几条。
It is a couple. Yeah, it's kind of like an exclave, but not quite. Yeah, it's a semi-exclusive space, but it is difficult to get into. So it's an exclusive, exclusive thing. So yeah, Point Roberts is actually in Washington State, part of Watcombe County. So, I first heard about Point Roberts from a podcast called Stop Podcasting Yourself, hosted by Dave, Shumka, and Graham Clark to Van Kuverites. And they are saying that some Van Kuverites go there because it's only 20 miles away or so
确实有几条。对，它有点像飞地，但又不太完全是。对，这是一个半独立的空间，但进去很不容易。所以这是一个孤立的、独特的区域。所以，是的，罗伯茨角其实属于华盛顿州，是沃特科姆县的一部分。我最早是通过一个叫《Stop Podcasting Yourself》的播客知道罗伯茨角的，这个节目由温哥华的两位主持人戴夫·舒姆卡和格雷姆·克拉克主持。他们说有些温哥华会去那里，因为只有大约20英里远
in order to pick up packages because shipping across the borders is actually quite expensive and also to get cheaper gas. It's also rumored to be the site of a federal witness protection program, like where they relocate. And I just happened to be in Seattle a little bit ago, and I also wanted to excuse to go to Vancouver and have you pay for it. So I just hired it to go, should I just play some border crossing? My first border crossing? All right. This is the piece arch border from Washington State, and the Kim. Exactly.
为了去取快递，因为跨境邮寄运费其实挺贵的，还能顺便加便宜的油。那里还有传言说是一个联邦证人保护计划的安置点。我正好不久前在西雅图，而且我也想要个借口去温哥华，还让你来出钱。所以我刚雇车去——我是不是该放一段过边境的录音？我的第一次过边境？好的。这是来自华盛顿州的和平拱门边境，以及金。没错。
Good, how are you? Good, thanks. So what's the purpose of your trip today? I'm going to Point and Roberts to report a story. It was just like a weird little part of America that you have to go through like two border crossings to get to. Yeah, it's just relatable. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
你好，最近怎么样？很好，谢谢。你这次旅行的目的是什么？我要去罗伯茨角报道一个故事。那只是美国一个奇怪的小地方，你得通过两个边境检查站才能到达。对，这挺有共鸣的。对，对，没错。
It's okay. It's so nervous. Yeah, can you hear my voice crack a little. Yeah, I think there's an instinct that arises in every Arab when they are crossing a border. Also a funny story. The last time I crossed a Canadian border, I was three or four years old going into the American side of Niagara Falls. And the border guard looked in was like, is everyone in this car American?
没关系。太紧张了。对，你能听到我的声音有点颤抖吗。对，我想每个阿拉伯人在过边境时都会产生一种本能。还有一个有趣的故事。我上次过加拿大边境时，我只有三四岁，正要进入尼亚加拉大瀑布的美国一侧。边防卫兵往车里一看，问：这车里的人全都是美国人吗？
And my dad's like, I'm Egyptian, she's American, and he's American in the back. And I go, no, I'm French, I'm being kidnapped. Oh my God. So there's some trauma around the Canadian board. Oh my God. Young Sharif. I was a little...
我爸说：我是埃及人，她美国人，后面那个也是美国人。然后我说：不，我是法国人，我被绑架了。天哪。所以关于加拿大边境我有一些创伤。天哪。小谢里夫。我当时有点……
You were a scamper. Yeah. Scamp is a much nicer than I was going to use. Okay. Are you making any stops in between? Uh, not in between, but I'm spending the night in Vancouver tonight. Vancouver. Have a good time.
你当时挺机灵的。“机灵”比我本来想用的词温和多了。好吧。你在中途有什么停留吗？呃，中途没有，但我今晚要在温哥华过夜。温哥华。玩得开心。
Thanks, man. Unscathed. Unscathed. Unscathed. Yeah, he was a very nice border crossing guard. He did ask if I had been arrested, which apparently is a thing like if you've been arrested you can't. You have to get like special permission to get into Canada if you have a criminal record in the States.
谢啦，老兄。毫发无损。毫发无损。毫发无损。是的，边境检查员人非常好。他确实问我有没有被捕过，显然如果被捕过的话——如果你在美国有犯罪记录，进加拿大好像需要获得某种特殊许可。
So anyway, it's another 20 or 30 minute drive to border number two. Welcome to Little America. I could just cross the border into Point Roberts. Scenic Loop Gateway. That sounds like something I would do. I like Scenic's loops. And basically immediately to my right
总之，去第二个边境还要开20到30分钟的车。欢迎来到小美国。我可以直接过境去罗伯茨角。观光环路入口。这听起来像我会做的事。我喜欢观光环路。基本上在我穿过边境的
after I cross the border, there's a place that receives packages. Open 24, seven. Automated retrieval. Vacuum-boot coffee, parcel services. It seems like there are a lot of places for parcel service. That was the theme throughout the entire time
右边，就有一个收快递的地方。24小时营业。自动取件。真空咖啡，包裹服务。看起来做包裹服务的挺多的。这就是我在罗伯茨角
in Point Roberts. Basically, any shop, no matter what it was selling or what it did, they offered to accept packages for you. Yeah. Oh It's good to be back To the familiar land of America God The gases and gallons. Oh, maybe it's not oh Interesting
待的整个期间的主题。基本上任何店铺，不管卖什么或者做什么，都提供帮你代收包裹的服务。对。哦，能回到
They see measure the gas and leaders here even in America. That's nuts. Wow leaders. Yeah, leaders. So, so what else did you find these little differences besides the leaders' revelation? Yeah, there wasn't much. It wasn't the most happening spot. Free wood. It's about like five square miles, a population of 1,013 and 14, according to the latest U.S. census in 2010.
美国这片熟悉土地感觉真好。天哪，连汽油都是按加仑算的。哦，等等，不是吗？哦，有意思。
But in the summertime, it can grow to about three or four times that, because a lot of Canadian vacationers come in. I went to the post office To closed Guess it's Saturday 150. Is there a school system? I saw that there is one primary school Mm-hmm. I believe it goes up to grade three or four Uh, and then everyone who is older than that has to go across four international borders every school day to go to school and blame Washington. Oh my god. Yeah, and I grew up in a fairly rural place with long school bus ride
他们在这连美国境内都用升来测量汽油。太疯狂了。哇，升。对，升。那么，除了“升”的发现，你还发现了哪些细微的差异？对，没多少。这地方算不上最热闹。免费木材。根据2010年美国最新人口普查，这里大约有五平方英里，人口1013人。
So I very much empathize and feel for you Any point Robert school kids who are listening. Driving down the Smeindrag, the biggest little store in Point Roberts. Hey. Eventually, I ran into their restaurant district. Oh shit. It's called the Reef Tavern. I have to eat there, right? Reef Tavern is calling to you. That's what we call you. I don't know. People know that. Yeah, it was fate. And at the reef cavern, I had a wonderful server named Tony, and he was just the absolute sweetest person and told me about how people from Canada go to that restaurant to get medium rare burgers
但在夏天，人口能增长到三到四倍，因为很多加拿大度假者会来。我去了邮局。关门了。猜是周六1：50。这里有学校吗？我看到有一所小学。嗯。我想它只开到三四年级或四四年级。然后比这年龄大的所有人，每个上学日都必须穿过四个国际边境去上学，还要抱怨华盛顿。天哪。是的，我在一个相当偏远、校车要开很久的地方长大。
because apparently the health codes in Canada are a little more strict about how, how, what's the bad at meat terms. Basically in Canada you have to cook it longer. So the real blood connoisseurs go to point Roberts. I'm a journalist from Oakland, California. Oh yeah. It's so cool that you ran into the other Oakland guy. Yeah, why? what are the odds?
所以我非常能感同身受，也很同情所有在听节目的罗伯茨角学童。沿着斯敏德拉格开车，这是罗伯茨角最大的一家小店。嘿。最后，我到了他们的餐厅区。哦，天哪。这叫礁石酒馆。我必须在那儿吃一顿，对吧？礁石酒馆在召唤你。我们就是这么叫你的。我不知道。大家知不知道。对，这就是缘分。在礁石酒馆，我遇到了一位非常棒的服务员叫托尼，他绝对是个最甜心的人，他跟我讲加拿大人怎么去那家餐厅吃五成熟的汉堡
And that's not even the weirdest part. Hold on, let me, let me play you a little, little something. Get ready to have your mind bone run prepared. It's a point of reference then. Yeah, thank you. Beautiful downtown foot rabbits right here. Beautiful downtown foot rabbits. Yeah, you guys have the same catchphrases. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there.
因为显然加拿大的健康法规对肉类烹饪程度的要求稍微严格一点。基本上在加拿大你得把它烤得更熟。所以真正的生肉爱好者都会去罗伯茨角。我是来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰的记者。哦，真的吗。你居然能偶遇另一个奥克兰人，太酷了。对，为什么？几率有多大？
People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there.
而这甚至还不是最奇怪的部分。等等，让我——让我放一段小插曲给你听。准备好让你的思维受到震撼吧。这就当作是一个参考点吧。对，谢谢。美丽的市中心小兔子。美丽的市中心小兔子。对，你们俩口头禅都一样。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。
People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there.
那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那里的居民。那，你最后弄清楚为什么汽油是用升计量的了吗？我没怎么去查证，但我的猜测主要是为了迎合加拿大人。没错。这样他们就知道自己加了多少油了。对，完全正确。事实上，在礁石酒馆里，我遇到了两位非常可爱的加拿大人，叫杰森和莉萨。他们就是那天来的，为了从一个不想跨境邮寄的eBay卖家那里取一把吉他循环踏板。哦，太棒了！对。所以这超级常见。常见到你随便就能碰上一个正在做这种事的人，他们对此习以为常。完全是这样。
People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. People down there. Yeah. Did you over figure out why the gas was in leaders? I didn't do much slew thing, but my guess is mainly to market to Canadians. Right. So they know how much gas they're putting in the gas. Yeah, exactly. And actually at the reef tavern, I saw two very lovely Canadians named Jason and Lisa. They had come in that very day to pick up a guitar loop pedal from a seller on eBay who didn't want to ship it across the border. Oh, perfect. Yeah. So it's super common. Come enough that you just run across a person who is doing these type of thing they're expecting. Totally.
下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。下面有人。对。你有没有弄明白为什么汽油是以升为单位的？我没怎么深究，但我的猜测主要是为了面向加拿大人市场。对。这样他们就知道自己加了多少油。对，没错。事实上，在礁石酒馆里，我遇到了两个非常可爱的加拿大人，名叫杰森和丽莎。他们那天刚好来到这里，从一个不想把吉他循环踏板寄过边境的eBay卖家那里取货。哦，太棒了。对。所以这非常普遍。普遍到你随便就能遇到一个在做这种事的人，他们对此也习以为常。完全是这样。
Totally. Looking into the town, Lisa saw that the average visitor spends less than 20 minutes. Only 5% of the visitors spend. Stay longer than that hour. Yeah, anyway, we've never been here before. It's super weird, but I like it. Cool, thank you guys so much. Yeah, I'll give you guys my phone number and he's going to serve. Making friends.
完全是这样。丽萨环顾了一下小镇，发现平均每个游客停留的时间不到20分钟。只有5%的游客停留。时间会超过一个小时。对，总之，我们以前从没来过这里。这地方超级奇怪，但我挺喜欢。太酷了，非常感谢你们。好啦，我把电话留给你们，他要继续上菜了。交朋友。
Yeah, making friends. And coincidentally, I showed them where I was staying in Vancouver. and it was basically right next to them and they invited me to drink wine and decorate their Christmas tree and it was just a really lovely evening. That's so cool. Yeah. Did you ever get confirmation about the witness production thing? Well, I guess I can neither confirm nor deny it. I actually reached out to Gerald Schor, the founder of the Witness Protection Program, and he responded back and he says, I have no information on Point Roberts, Washington, which I guess you can take to be like anything you want.
对，交朋友。巧合的是，我给他们看了我在温哥华住的地方，基本上就在他们隔壁，他们邀请我去喝红酒、装饰他们的圣诞树，那真是一个非常美好的夜晚。太酷了。对。你最终得到关于证人保护计划的证实了吗？好吧，我想我只能无可奉告。我其实联系了证人保护计划的创立者杰拉尔德·肖尔，他回信说，我对华盛顿州的罗伯茨角没有任何信息，我想你想怎么理解都可以。
which I guess you can take to be like anything you want. Um, that's awesome. Nice adventure in the name of the show. Yeah, thanks for, thanks for the expense. No problem. Thanks, Rief. Yeah, thanks. This special thanks to Nate Berg, Lauren Sporer, and Pete Earley for helping Shreef out with that story. We have one more mini story coming up next with the King of the Coda, Kurt Colestead, after
我想你想怎么理解都可以。嗯，太棒了。以节目的名义进行了一次美好的冒险。对，谢谢你报销费用。不客气。谢谢谢里夫。对，谢谢。特别感谢内特·伯格、劳伦·斯波尔和皮特·厄利帮助谢里夫完成了这个报道。接下来，在尾声之后，我们还有最后一个小故事，来自尾声之王库尔特·科尔斯泰德。
this. So, every year, at the end of the year and the beginning of the next year, we do these mini stories. And the funny thing is, is that the mini stories were so popular that we began doing them curtain-eye, I'm in this studio with Kurt. Kurt-eye started doing kind of a mini stories almost every episode, like as Dakota, because there's always some story that Kurt has that relates to the story we just told. But this one we never found
所以，每年年底和年初，我们都会做这些小故事。有趣的是，这些小故事太受欢迎了，以至于我和库尔特——我在这个录音室里和库尔特在一起。库尔特开始几乎每期节目都做一些小故事，作为尾声，因为总有一些库尔特的故事跟我们刚刚讲的故事相关。但这个故事我们一直没找到
up place for exactly. Yeah, this one just never quite fit yet. And I really wanted to tell you. Oh, there we go. And we have the perfect opportunity. Yeah. So basically last year, the Ford Motor Company made big news into Troy when they said they were going to buy and renovate Michigan Central Station.
确切合适的地方。对，这个故事就是一直不太合拍。而我真的很想讲给你听。哦，来吧。我们终于有了完美的机会。对，基本上在去年，福特汽车公司在底特律搞了个大新闻，他们宣布要买下并翻新密歇根中央车站。
And this is like a big train station, sort of like Grand Central terminal type train station. Yeah, it's huge, old, beautiful. It's like Grand Central much, much taller. And it's in downtown Detroit? Yeah, it's really visible when you're coming in on the highway. It's just like one of the most visible tallest structures on the side of the city. And so Ford, who based still in Detroit, bought this, and they're going to run a bit of it. And suddenly there is all this news around the fact that they're going to, you know, come out and do
这是一个很大的火车站，有点像中央车站那种类型的火车站。对，它又大、又老、又漂亮。它有点像中央车站，但比它高得多。它在底特律市中心吗？对，当你从高速公路进来时，它非常显眼。它绝对是城市边缘最显眼、最高的建筑之一。所以底特律本土的福特公司买下了它，并准备进行翻新。突然之间，到处都是关于他们要
this big press conference and explain to the city what their plan was for this old building that had been deserted for so long. And then lead up to that big press conference, someone anonymously approached the Ford Museum with this surprising artifact. It was this big round antique clock that used to hang really prominently on one of the walls of the station. Let's face it, train passengers needed to know the time, so the clock is huge. It's been gone for a very long time now, and Bill Ford says he couldn't believe it when a secret approach was made to get that clock back. Somebody must have really loved it and loved the train station because they took very good care of it.
召开大型新闻发布会的消息，向这座城市解释他们对这座荒废了这么久的古老建筑有什么计划。在那场大型新闻发布会之前，有人匿名联系了福特博物馆，送上了一件令人惊奇的文物。这是一个巨大的圆形古董钟，以前就挂在车站的一面墙上，非常显眼。想想看，火车旅客需要知道时间，所以这个时钟非常巨大。它已经消失了很长时间了，比尔·福特说，当有人秘密送回这个时钟时，他简直不敢相信。一定有人非常深爱它、深爱这个火车站，因为他们把它保护得很好。
So somebody stole this gigantic clock from a train station and then they returned it when they heard that the train station is going to be renovated. Yeah, it's pretty remarkable. And we don't really know much about the person who returned the clock. I mean, maybe they just took it to try to help preserve it. Maybe they weren't even the original thief. It's possible they bought it or found it. Let me bet. Yeah, right? Or inherited it. All we really know for sure is that they carefully wrapped it up and then told the folks at the Ford Museum where to find it. What do you mean where to find it? All we really know for sure is that they carefully wrapped it up and then told the folks at the Ford Museum where to find it. What do you mean where to find it? Like they left it somewhere and they like a lot of a sleeve. They left it like alongside of the side of a building. There are pictures of
所以有人从火车站偷了这个巨大的时钟，然后在听说火车站要翻新时又把它还了回来。对，这太了不起了。而且我们对还钟的人知之甚少。我的意思是，也许他们拿走它只是为了帮忙保护它。也许他们甚至不是最初的小偷。他们可能是买来的，或者是捡到的。让我猜猜。对吧？或者是继承的。我们真正能确定的是，他们小心翼翼地把它包好，然后告诉福特博物馆的人去哪里找它。你是指去哪里找？我们真正能确定的是，他们小心翼翼地把它包好，然后告诉福特博物馆的人去哪里找它。你是指去哪里找？就像他们把它留在某个地方，比如塞在什么地方。他们把它留在了一栋建筑物的旁边。有照片记录了
this. You can see it like the he just kind of wrapped it up and like kind of strapped it in and then high-tailed it and then high-tailed it and just texted that one again. Yeah. That's amazing. Just come and grab the clock but bring a couple guys on a track. Wow, it's amazing that he felt so inspired to give it back. I mean, I think this is sort of a civic icon. It's this stunning, massive, bozart structure, and it was designed by the same architects as Grand Central Terminal in New York.
这个过程。你能看到它，他把它包起来，绑好，然后火速溜走，然后火速溜走，又给那边发了条短信。对。这太神奇了。直接去拿时钟吧，但带上一辆卡车和几个人。哇，太惊人了，他竟然深受鼓舞把它送回来。我的意思是，我认为这算是某种城市地标。这是一座惊艳、庞大的布杂艺术建筑，它是由纽约中央车站的同一个建筑师设计的。
And the idea originally was that it would be the Grand Central of the Midwest. It would handle all this passenger and freight traffic and be kind of, you know, this landmark in the city. So they put up these, you know, it's filled with all these beautiful details, these marble walls, vaulted ceilings, copper skylights, and it's huge. It's 18 stories tall. So there are restaurants and shops down below and then office spaces above. And so, but obviously it fell on hard time. So what went wrong with the Michigan Central Station?
它最初的想法是成为中西部的中央车站。它将处理所有的客运和货运交通，成为这座城市的一个地标。所以他们建造了这些——里面充满了所有这些美丽的细节，大理石墙面、拱形天花板、铜制天窗，而且它非常巨大。它有18层楼高。所以下面有餐厅和商店，上面是办公空间。但是很显然，它遭遇了不景气。那么，密歇根中央车站究竟出了什么问题呢？
Well, a lot of things arguably, but the rise of the car definitely helped drive it out of business. Yeah. More people were driving out to the suburbs and the city itself and the station fell into disuse. And at first the offices cleared out and then the shops and restaurants started to close down. And then finally in the 80s, the ticket booth shut down,
嗯，可以说原因很多，但汽车的崛起绝对是把它逼出业务的主要原因。对。越来越多的人开车去郊区而不是留在市区，这个车站渐渐荒废了。起初办公室搬空了，然后商店和餐厅也开始关门。最后在80年代，售票处也关闭了，
and basically the whole place was just locked up. Well, and they just abandoned it. It was left empty at that point. Yeah, and there was talk over the years of tearing it down, but it had this status as a landmark, and that helped protect it from demolition. Wow. They came up with plans to try to reuse this,
基本上整个地方都被锁上了。嗯，他们直接把它抛弃了。当时它就被闲置了空着。对，这些年来一直有关于把它拆除的讨论，但它具有地标的身份，这帮助它免遭拆除。哇。他们想出了各种重新利用它的计划，
like ideas to turn it into a police station, or a convention center, or even a casino. And none of those panned out, so the building just kind of kept being sold and changing hands. And the owners before Ford finally did do some work on it, like they drained the basement and they had to send new windows and they put up a security fence. Right. So obviously that must have happened after the clock was stolen. Yeah. Yeah. They definitely were aware that things were disappearing from the building and I think they wanted to put a stop to that.
比如把它变成警察局、会议中心甚至赌场的想法。但这些都没有成功，所以这栋建筑只能不断被出售和转手。在福特之前的拥有者最终确实对它做了一些工作，比如他们排干了地下室的水，装了新窗户，还建了安全围栏。没错。所以很显然，那一定是在时钟被偷之后发生的。对。是的。他们绝对意识到了这栋建筑里的东西在不断消失，我想他们是想制止这种行为。
I mean, a lot of people were visiting this building to take pictures or just explore it, but along the way, hundreds of artifacts were taken to. So the clock is really just one piece of the puzzle. There were lots of little things taken from this building. I would imagine over the years. Yeah, a really large piece that took multiple people to move, but definitely one of many things. And returning it actually started this kind of bigger movement.
我的意思是，很多人来这栋建筑拍照或只是探索，但在这个过程中，成百上千的文物也被顺走了。所以时钟其实只是拼图的一部分。有许多小物件从这栋建筑里被拿走了。我想这些年来肯定不少。对，这是一个需要好几个人才能搬动的大物件，但绝对是众多被拿走的东西之一。而把它归还，实际上引发了一场更大规模的行动。
Because once Ford had the clock in hand, they were able to put out a call and say, hey, look, somebody returned this clock. If anybody else has stuff, maybe you could bring it back to. And you won't get in trouble. No questions asked, leave it on the side of a building. Right, right. And it worked.
因为一旦福特拿到时钟，他们就可以发出呼吁说，嘿，看，有人把这个时钟还回来了。如果其他人还有什么东西，也许你们也可以把它带回来。而且你们不会惹上麻烦。既往不咎，把它留在某栋建筑旁边就行。对，对。而且这真的管用了。
Dozens of people have now come forward to offer up old station artifacts, including fountains and plaster medallions and light fixtures and all kinds of stuff. Wow. Wow. Yeah. And Ford actually has a wish list too. They want back things like the ticket window grills, elevator trance and panels, other clocks that have disappeared over the years, and basically, you know, anything that is sort of considered critical to the historic character of the building. Right. And what are they planning to restore it as it was, where they plan to do with all these artifacts? Well, some things will probably go back into the building, and others will
现在已经有几十人站出来，主动提供旧车站的文物，包括喷泉、石膏奖章、灯具以及各种各样的东西。哇。哇。是的。福特其实也有一份愿望清单。他们想要回诸如售票窗口格栅、电梯门框面板、这些年来消失的其他时钟，基本上，你知道，任何被认为对这栋建筑历史风貌至关重要东西。没错。他们计划把它修复成什么样？他们打算怎么处理所有这些文物呢？嗯，有些东西可能会回到建筑内部，而其他的则会
end up in local museums. And one of the sort of side benefits is that some of these things can be used to model copies too, right? So if you have one plaster medallion, you can make a bunch of other ones, but in the renovated building. Yeah. Well, that makes sense. So is the idea that this thing is going to be like a passenger train terminal again, or is it something different?
最终进入当地博物馆。其中一个好处是，其中一些东西也可以用来制作复制品，对吧？所以如果你有一个石膏奖章，你就可以在翻新后的建筑里复制出一堆其他的来。对，这说得通。所以大家的想法是，这东西以后会再次成为一个客运火车站，还是说会有所不同？
No, it's going to be something different. Basically, Fort Hyrd Snowhead, this sort of famous international design firm, to help them build out a new campus. They're calling it the Quirk Town campus and it's gonna be the center for Ford to develop autonomous vehicles and other urban road related technologies in a nice central area where they can do like actual on the road testing.
不，它会变得有所不同。基本上，福特聘请了斯诺黑特这家著名的国际设计事务所来帮助他们打造一个新的园区。他们称之为科克敦园区，这将成为福特开发自动驾驶汽车以及其他城市道路相关技术的中心，在一个交通便利的中心区域，他们可以进行实际的道路测试。
And the station itself is gonna be the heart of this and it's gonna be repopulated actually with a lot of the same things I had before, like restaurants and shops, and above there are going to be offices, but also condos now. And the idea is that Ford can move some of its people and its partner organizations up into these spaces. Have you seen pictures of the artifacts and the renovation at all? Yeah, there's some great images of the clock,
而车站本身将成为这一切的核心，实际上它将重新容纳许多以前有过的设施，比如餐厅和商店，上面将是办公空间，现在还会有公寓。这样的设想是，福特可以将部分员工和合作伙伴组织搬进这些空间里。你见过那些文物和翻新工程的照片吗？对，有一些非常棒的时钟照片，
and it's sitting outside wrapped up. And there are a lot of historic photos that kind of show what was there, what's missing, and Ford's plan for what this building is going to look like when they're all done with this campus. That's awesome. Can you put them on the website for us? Oh, yeah, of course. That soundsffleman, Katie Minkle, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, Sheree Fusef, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Riel, Taren Masa, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in
它正放在外面包装好。还有很多历史照片展示了这里曾经的模样、缺失的部分，以及福特对这个园区完工后外观的规划。太棒了。你能把它们放到网站上给我们看看吗？哦，当然可以。听起来很棒。谢谢凯蒂·明克、库尔特·科尔斯泰德、德兰尼·霍尔、谢里夫·优素福、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、肖恩·里尔、塔伦·马萨、乔·罗森伯格、维维安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的无线电街区制作。
beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our sticker-loving coin carrying listeners, just like you. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But the real 99PI HQ is at 99PI.org. RDO-TOPIOR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的创始成员，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们由像你这样喜爱贴纸、随身携带硬币的听众资助。你可以在Facebook上找到99%隐形，并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，也可以在推特上@节目 99PI org，Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也可以。但真正的99PI总部在 99PI.org。R-A-D-I-O-T-O-P-I-A 点 O-R-G。你们好。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。